it's elon musk's twitter now by the way
yeah yeah yeah yeah elon musk you got a
board
all the time
and the first day they they go uh he's
gonna have a what is it called a non-um
authoritative role
like when he bought the percentage there
was like a clause like this basically he
doesn't have a say a passive role or
something like that and then the day
later was like he's on the board
and of course you want him on the board
you want one of the most successful
humans in history especially in the tech
sector to be on the board of an app he's
the best twitter account
yeah so of course you want that guy
representing your brand and he's not as
dangerous as like a trump was you know
trump's twitter was awesome yeah like he
doesn't have the same radio activity
it's controversial but it's not the same
yeah that's the guy that should own the
majority of twitter now what do you
think
he's doing this for what is the
inspiration behind this
i mean i know what people are hoping
that it is yeah like but what do you
think of this yeah i don't know like i
mean i'm i just trust that he's like a
savvy business sort of like mover and
that he knows what he's doing and kind
of what he wants the outcome to be but
i mean
equity in some major platform in terms
of like you have all these billionaires
that buy up
like media companies so like bezos buys
up washington post like msnbc the ms is
microsoft you know i mean like it's
owned by all these media companies are
owned by billionaires so i'm assuming
he's looking at this is like oh this is
the new wave of media so i'm gonna try
to buy in to the newest to the new point
that would be really [ __ ] smart so
um were you gonna say something else i
think he wants
twitter on the tesla interface
in cars
interesting for what reason
right now he has spotify there's a few
that he doesn't have and so i'm pretty
sure they're blocking him from like
including them in there because their
interface is like you can't adjust it oh
really yeah but you can't buy apps you
can't add apps like that yeah and then
and so what would be the advantage of
having twitter on just makes it more
cool and exactly my cars come with
twitter
as you have self-driving
now that's interesting him being able to
like buy up or leaks buy shares of these
companies that he wants to incorporate
in the tesla's i think that's kind of
fun
but to what mark was saying i think is
quite interesting is that once you
become a billionaire you need a media
apparatus to protect your wealth and
it's not even billionaire like back in
the day you just need like jeff bezos
needs something that's pumping out
positive bazel [ __ ] yeah and crushing
his enemies i'll do it rupert murdoch
every single one of them so the media is
really an arm of the powerful and we've
seen that in terms of
powerful politicians but we also have to
look at it as in terms of like powerful
businessmen and in america the
businessmen and women you could argue
have just as much influence in the
government as
the government right or maybe they're in
cahoots a different discussion who gives
a [ __ ] uh we'll change it all when i'm
president
no but uh but i like that him going wow
the the information landscape is not
washington post the information
landscape is the apps themselves
so if i'm an owner of these apps not
does he it's not that he can control
truth
but what he can do
is control
the erasure
of truth okay so remember he was
tweeting a lot about covet early on and
he was like a little skeptical about
kovac right and he saw tweets getting
taken down people getting taken down for
it
he if they were gonna stop the work at
his factory and all this other [ __ ]
he can allow information that can combat
a washington post article without
getting wiped down
right like there are certain people that
control the narratives what's acceptable
what's not acceptable on twitter
some of the not acceptable stuff works
out potentially in his favor right now
he can fight to make sure that's still
there so he might not be as deliberate
as a washington post would be which is
like
jeff why jeff bezos is the best man ever
yeah but he can
make sure an article that is [ __ ] on
bezos gets just as much light yeah as an
article so there's a smart move like why
would you control the source of the
information when you could just control
the marketplace the marketplace yeah now
if he starts to have the same influence
that a bezos has
on the washington post where you start
to see it really being skewed in elon's
favor that's where things get dangerous
that is kind of dangerous but apparently
this is their solution to just not
having them buy the company outright
that's what somebody said they were
afraid because he's rich enough to just
buy [ __ ] twitter whatever offer you
want he can make it yeah i mean 300
billion that's fine he could do that
so they were like just give him the
board seat let's just keep him happy
let's give him 10
and then this way he doesn't own the
whole [ __ ] thing because there's
there's one human being on earth rich
enough to buy out twitter outright and
it's him wow he loves twitter i mean
yeah
yeah i'm also assuming that he sees this
as like an arm of his brand in terms of
like marketing yeah like he doesn't
spend any money on marketing and his
twitter is the marketing for spacex and
tesla yup so he's like at the very least
i'll just have equity in my marketing
yeah tesla doesn't spend on traditional
marketing dollars because he's there
exactly now question
he's um
he's he suggested i think twitter's also
working on an edit function for tweets
did you see this yeah he had a poll
should twitter allow an edit button and
then and then apparently twitter came
out and said they were also working on
it or they have been maybe for a while
so maybe this is them talking about i
thought they had that already no no
no but like
why is that advantageous
so i mean i'm assuming their thing would
be like oh you can correct
misinformation or like a [ __ ] typo
that kills a tweet but just
delete
right but if you have this tweet that
goes super crazy viral like you can
correct it and you can edit things to
make them more accurate like i'm sure
that would be like the marketing spin
that they would want this so the problem
with it is like
you get everybody to retweet something
you say then you edit it into saying
yeah that happens on reddit yeah like
you can edit like reddit comments uh and
so like some people just do that for fun
like yo upload this comment to make the
post look crazy and then it'll get crazy
uploads and then they'll just change the
comments to just be some wild [ __ ] and
then it's like why did everyone upload
this but then but it'll say edited at
the top so then you can kind of put the
clues together gotchu
okay at least i'm just trying to
understand like what is the advantage of
this edit buddy it's like taking down a
youtube video and then putting back up
it's out of the algorithm yeah that's
how it hurts you so if it's like oh it's
just a [ __ ] typo i would love to
correct this i don't want this sitting
there as it gets momentum then you just
you can correct it uh because articles
can edit themselves on or not edit
themselves but like new york times can
put like an addendum to an article and
be like no oh like this is actually a
correction and if twitter is looking at
themselves as a newspaper it's like oh
we should allow journalists like all
every journalist in the world that
twitter is their home base now i'm
understanding i was thinking it was
about like you said something foul and
you're gonna get canceled for it but
it's
editing it's the new york times editing
their headline that's on twitter right
it's the new york times
that's what i'm assuming i don't know
kovac killed this many people no no no
now that you know it didn't don't put
out that new tweet that no one's gonna
see nobody's gonna see you edit the one
everybody saw
correct your [ __ ] and if you don't
correct it
we're going to look at it as
misinformation and we will take it down
right now oh interesting
that's what i'm assuming i don't know
but like twitter's biggest thing is like
journalists and like academics and like
people like having hot takes and like
trying to combat misinformation and [ __ ]
that's like the biggest challenge i mean
one way to combat misinformation is be
able to edit it i thought it was a
cancel thing but now that i know it's
about like information
yeah but i guess you could go back like
if you said some crazy [ __ ] back in the
day yeah 12 years old on twitter you can
go back just change the words a little
bit i mean you can also delete the
tweets
like twitter should offer a function
that allows you to delete a tweet like
twitter should just be like how long
would you like your tweets to exist here
yeah
a year cool one month cool you want to
delete it every single day
cool yeah and um yeah i think that would
make it so sick i'm giving up mad ip
right now yeah
i wish twitter had like like a flag box
like hey here's all the tweets that you
should consider deleting you know yeah
if it just had like a keyword search
called your drafts
but like i wish there was just like a
little thing that's like oh yeah you
said this word back in the day like once
we have twitter for 50 years yeah and
like we're saying words now like we're
saying trans now but what if trans is a
slur in 50 years and you don't say trans
anymore i wish twitter could like update
and be like hey you have a bunch of
tweets that say trans like do you want
to fix that yeah and just like like give
you an alert well you can look up yeah
by the way but they should do it for you
as well if they said that you could just
have a little inbox it's like yeah you
were a while back flagged tweets yeah
that's a great yeah hey these words are
deemed sensitive now they're not uh
illegal on our platform but people find
them sensitive you said this back in the
day you might have been drunk and forgot
yeah just because it hurts their brand
that like they have won such a good
search feature that everyone can look up
anything but it also hurts them that oh
i could put up something and then in 10
years it looks crazy and then people
kill me i mean low-key like
no i just kind of like seeing how people
used to work
yeah you know
that's true but low-key like you don't
like seeing how you used to wildlife
that's a different thing yeah
like i stopped using twitter in terms of
like feeding with content i was like the
risk is too high
it doesn't help me do anything it
doesn't help my career it doesn't sell
tickets it doesn't give people to the
podcast but
it only hurts me if i say one thing
wrong so it's not worth it so i stopped
tweeting that's bad for twitter twitter
wants or should want funny people
yeah but if funny people are scared
charlemagne is not on [ __ ] twitter no
more he used to be hilarious on twitter
yeah so you maybe
you've removed the funny people that say
things that are dangerous for your
platform and maybe that's what you want
so maybe that's i guess a good thing but
i think the best platform is where the
funniest people are on there i mean we
made twitter pop in when everybody was
wilding out on yeah
you